you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum I'm not related
recording I was just pretending I was
recording hey guys how are you it is
it's me Michael Rosenbaum in the flesh
with inside of you with Michael
Rosenbaum is the podcast and guess what
we're going to announce something really
cool it's the inside a podcast patreon I
didn't even know if a patreon was I
thought it was Parthenon I met I kept
mispronouncing it but then I heard that
it's a cool way to connect with your
fans and give them things that they
never would get and I'm reading some
stuff too it's not reading it's just
like points that I have to just kind of
I just can't remember everything it's
like if you've been listening to my show
for a while now I think you know how
much this podcast means to me and how
it's helped thousands of people out
there I try to normalize mental health I
think that's what we've done here and I
get thousands of letters and you guys
have come up to me at cons and we've had
a cry together and it just gets emails
all the time and I read them I really do
it makes me feel like I'm doing
something good here and I think we're
doing something good here
so I love this show it gives me purpose
but more importantly I love you guys
because I wouldn't be doing it if it
wasn't for you and it means a lot that
you guys listen every day I just I had
no idea I even have a fan base so that's
why I'm starting this patreon I want to
get closer to you guys you guys can get
a little closer to me but let's be
respectful to our fellow patrons and
myself week to week my podcast we talked
to actors and celebrities but there's
not a whole lot of room for deeper
interaction between the wall of the
podcast right that's why I'm excited to
share what we have here I wanted to
create a safe space that allows you guys
to talk in a community talk about mental
health I'm at the podcast talking about
me if you want so if you listen every
week to inside of you you're gonna love
this you're gonna love this extra stuff
if you don't you're still going to love
it you're gonna get some really cool
stuff that you won't get on my regular
feeds or my social media we're gonna
have bonus podcast episodes exclusive
new video segments personal Q&A segments
with me you're gonna get inside of me
that's going to be interesting
I think this is gonna be a real fight I
have fun with stuff like this
look look if this really blows huh I
don't just this I don't like to do
something really cool I am going to
throw a party for all my patreon I mean
if it blows up to the point where hey
this is I can afford a party I can throw
a party we're gonna do karaoke and 80s
if some of you are old or I had an 83
year old just cameo me I'll get some 60s
or 70s karaoke songs in there we'll have
some pig in blankets you know those
things are the little hot dogs and a
little bread if you're a vegan or
whatever it's cool we won't have that
look if you love inside of you if you
love what we're doing here and you want
to support our mission and normalizing
mental health having some fun and
talking about real things with
celebrities and real issues and
normalizing mental health this is for
you so I invite you to join our patreon
today Blanche and get ready to receive
some badass awesome content from yours
truly I think you're gonna dig it look
at those tears of what you'll get and
all right Rosenbaum signing off I think
that was long enough but I'll see you
soon
I'll see you inside of me beautiful
[Music]
you